and we will be live in about 10 seconds
from now
fine i think we're live now we are
we are so well welcome to this meeting
of cabinet everyone
uh it's 3 30 and we've started
uh will he do a roll call please anne
leader we start with you yes i can see
and hear the proceedings
thank you councillor pemberton
[Music]
i can see and hear the proceedings
clearly thank you chairman
thank you councillor barker i can see
and okay sorry councillor barker i can
see and hear the proceedings however
i'm being a little bit slow when i put
that when i
demute myself things are on a crawl
around here
okay thank you we'll take that into
account my counselor cargill
uh casa cargill i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you councillor harvey confirmed
can see in here thank you
thank you councillor jennings tesla
jennings i can hear you see all
proceedings thank you councillor kettle
that's the kettle i can see and hear all
proceedings thank you councillor parry
councillor parry here good afternoon
everybody
i can see and hear all the proceedings
thank you
thank you councillor shenton good
afternoon uh i can hear and see all the
proceedings
thank you thank you we also have
councillors june eden dixon with us
thank you thank you
uh so apologies for absence and
we've got apologies from councillor or
donald
thank you uh
disclosures of interest any disclosures
of interest
i'll take that as a no oh sorry leader i
do have a
declaration of interest it's on the item
13
on the ward member there and there's a
an allocation in the self-funding
for ulster flood defense scheme thank
you councillor cargill
uh minutes with the exception of the
issues on the minutes already raised by
councillor harvey
are there any other issues on the
minutes
i'll take that as a no
so our student unit is just also
reported she's a world councillor in
ulster
so in that case
we'll move on and uh
first item five on the agenda is
uh
sorry i'm just checking i've got this
right
sorry item four on the agenda
is working together with warwick
district council
uh i'm assuming that everyone has read
the paper
uh there's an awful lot of detail in the
paper
i'm not going to go through it in detail
because i'm sure you've already
uh background is i would just say
uh the fundamental issue in a change in
an increasingly challenging world
where reorganization of local government
is on the agenda
the question is what's the best
sustainable option for our residents
and in my view and as this paper
demonstrates
combining with warwick district council
offers the best option for our residents
and i think the best option for our
residents should be the most important
criteria
for making the decision and if you look
at the summary the purpose of this
report is to seek
recommendation to counsel on the
principle of further integration
including the potential full merger with
warwick district council be incorporated
into the policy
framework of the council
i would just say before i open it up for
debate
that last night i received a copy of an
email from the leader of the county
council in relation to this item
the purpose of the email was to
understand whether the meetings this
week are to take decisions
to support the merger or whether it is
the beginning of a process which will
include consultation
it's clear from the recommendations the
decisions which have been sought is the
start of a process
and to agree a vision for the future
direction for the two authorities
the decisions will allow for progress to
be made in developing an implementation
program
and development of a formal submission
to the secretary state
however its submission will be subject
to a future decision
of cabinet and council i can assure the
leader of the county council there will
be full consultation
with republican stakeholders which will
include county council
i would make one observation on this
that if one actually looks at when
the county council were going to make a
submission for strategic case for change
their list of partners that they would
engage with
was health town and parish councils
voluntary and community sector employers
in big business
warwickshire and coventry lep west
midlands combined authority
warwickshire police and universities and
colleges
he will spot the uh obvious omission
from that list so
uh i will open that up for debate to
members of cabinet
right uh counselor junior do you want to
report on behalf of overview and
scrutiny
before that happens chairman could i
have a word
yes um
this is clearly the start of a process
which is going to be
arguably the the most important process
stroke decision
that this council can possibly take
um i don't think we should be under any
illusions
that there aren't going to be some
difficulties
along the way there are some naughty
problems that it
is quite possible to spot uh
at this stage that will need to be
resolved
that said i am of the firm
view that given the alternatives
in front of us and given our
responsibility to secure the future
of the uh the interests of the residents
of the district as best we can i have no
doubt
that the move towards an integrated
single south warwickshire council is in
the best interests
and it is the best option that is
available to us
and if we are not seen to be taking a
leadership
role in determining the future and
direction
of this council others will do it
to us it's important
that we are masters of our own destiny
that we make the case to the public that
we persuade
the public to support the move we are
hopefully going to take
and this is the opening to a bright
future
for south warwickshire where stratford
and its residents will play their
full part this is a positive exercise
with issues and problems to be overcome
not difficulties to obstruct us from our
target
thank you very much thank you councillor
harvey
i appreciate exactly what you said i
think it is the precursor to a
bright future i'm now going to take uh
councillors pemberton barker and cargill
in that order
and come to councillor junior for the
view of osce last
councillor pemberton thank thank you
chairman um
as ever councillor harvey is eloquent
and um picks up a number of themes that
i would
have mentioned myself i would say
in addition that um
whilst this is also a this is absolutely
a positive step
that seeks to shape the destiny
of uh local government
across south warwickshire for the
benefit of all of our residents
it is beholden upon us as community
leaders
to make it absolutely clear that our
analysis and that of our senior officers
is that there is change coming to the
way in which
local government particularly in
warwickshire is organized
and that by taking no action whatsoever
we will be a passenger in that process
and there is no there is no prospect
whatsoever
that the current structures as they
stand for all our authorities here today
will stand the test of the medium term
and by the medium term i i look towards
the sort of middle of this decade
and so we must be positive in seeking
the best
solution for our residents because to do
nothing would be
nothing short of an abdication of our
responsibility as community leaders
and i wholeheartedly support as
embarking on
what will be a challenging process
towards the best outcome for our
residents and i firmly believe that
an ever closer relationship uh with
warwick district
is given the options currently in front
of us
the best route to go thank you thank you
councillor pemberton
and i think you do well to remind us of
our role as community leaders
in terms of making sure we do the best
for our residents and convince them it
is the best
councillor barker um you won't be
surprised to hear me say that i'm
actually really excited about this
um being a little bit of a change junkie
it's that would come as no surprise but
what i want to do and what i think we
all want to do is the very very
best we can for south warwickshire we're
a very distinctive place
we have commonalities with warwick we
have differences as well
but together we will undoubtedly be
stronger as
one super district and therefore will
get a better deal and do a better job
for our residents
just touching on my own portfolio of
housing i'm very struck
which includes housing um i'm very
struck by how much
um today on the agenda actually we've
got that is housing intertwined with
well-being
and i think that that is one of the most
important things that we will be working
towards
with warwick who of course have um
a housing portfolio as well so there is
of actual houses not people um and that
it that in itself
is really exciting that we are going to
be able to provide
better service for our residents and
that's what it's all about
so i'm very excited and i'm commending
this to us
thanks thank you councillor barker
uh the paradox of local government be
exciting has not passed me by
councillor cargill thank you leader
well it is interesting to note that we
started this process
well before the current pandemic
had struck so we knew that there was
mileage in this
and that the the merging of these two
organizations together
even if it's at a higher level working
closer ever closer with merged positions
for example
but the pandemic has just forced us into
a focus
a little bit more on the needs now a lot
of
things have been said about the
analogies of this merger
and uh many of them marriage related
uh and i know the chief executive said
well no so it's going to be a completely
new account
it's not not a marriage but the course
of true love doesn't always run smoothly
and occasionally we will have a little
few hiccups along the way a few spats
and i'm sure but at the end of the day
i believe that this is the right way to
move
for our residents and that's for the
interests of our residents
thank you leader thank you councillor
cargill councillor jennings
okay as a man as a man of few words
there's change coming and we need to be
proactive
in order to gain maximum benefit for the
people of this district
we're taking a step forward in the right
direction
thank you councillor jennings uh
perfectly succinct
uh councillor kettle i will try to be
the same
this is not the first time we have
sought to work with other authorities
um since i have been a member of this
council
we have worked with both um cherwell and
south northamptonshire
um they don't always work but this one
has a very different flavor
and a very different logic running all
the way through it
in a way that the others were less so
so this is not new for this authority it
is probably the best option
we have and it is an excellent option
going forward
thank you councillor kettle uh
councillor parry thank you leader um
well joe uh councillor barker basically
stole my thunder because i was going to
go down the route of exciting but in
addition to that
i think it's actually totally unique i
don't believe there are two
other um so well matched uh adjacent
local authorities
as warwick district and stratford
district our connectivity
both in geographic and our economic and
business profiles
together with the tourism that flows
between
one side of the district to the other
really gives us so much positivity and i
think
i think it will regenerate just starting
to progress
starting the progress of this potential
merger and looking at better ways of
working together
it is exciting it's unique but i think
it's the great platform for total
recovery from
from covid so fully support it thank you
leader
thank you councillor parry uh some good
points well made
and i thought it was very interesting
looking at the uh
uh travel to work areas that were in the
appendix and it just shows how
intertwined our two districts are
councillor shenton thank you leader
um i think from the uh what we've seen
from the operations portfolio in
particular
uh things such as the waste contract and
the mirth project
i clearly demonstrate uh just how well
we can work together for the benefit
of the the whole of the south
warwickshire district
uh i'd i'd and it it for me this is
definitely the way forward
i fully support this paper um 100
and uh it won't be without its
challenges
but then life generally isn't without
its challenges so
you know hey ho let's move on
thanks thank you councillor shenton and
it's interesting that you've picked up
where we are
are already working together how well
it's going
councillor junior the view from osc
please
yes there was a problem with overview
and scrutiny with the lateness of the
papers
and given that this as has been said uh
is a change that will have the scale of
the change the benefits the risks the
mitigations
uh of the proposal are huge
the overview and scrutiny committee
wanted to to do
its proper job of scrutiny
and because of the lateness of the
papers they've arranged a special
meeting
called for the 17th of february and then
there will be a briefing for councillors
as you know on the 16th of february
and once they overview and scrutiny has
had the chance to
uh look at uh or have the briefing and
look at all the paperwork
thoroughly uh they will do their proper
job and then we'll feed into
um the the um uh the council meeting
so i just wanted to update you on that
that uh there will be this special
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
on the 17th of february
there's a lot of work to be done uh and
we want to do our job properly
thank you councillor junior and we were
very pleased to make sure the
overview and scrutiny had the full
opportunity
to actually study the proposals not only
that
uh we have arranged for the briefing
by members of delight so that all
councillors have the opportunity
to be fully informed i now have
councillor harvey
and council of pemberton wishing to
speak councillor harvey
can i just make the uh the procedural
point that
while i'm very happy that osc should be
involved in the discussions
uh in considering what what's going
forward the role
of osc is to deal with decisions taken
uh by cabinet amongst other things and
that's not appropriate in this
particular case since
what the cabinet is considering is
merely a recommendation to council
and it's for council to have the major
debate about whether this is the right
thing
the right course of action thank you
thank you councillor harvey councillor
pemberton
i was merely going to observe that
um as has been said earlier that
this is the start of a process and this
cabinet
welcomes the opportunity for the
critical friend that is overview and
scrutiny
to contribute positively and in a
forward-thinking way
to the uh journey that we are embarking
upon
and um i i look forward to
positive input from colleagues at osc
in helping shaping the very best future
for our residents thank you
thank you councillor pemberton so i
think every member of cabinet has
actually spoken
and i got the distinct impression that
there was strong support
so before i move to the recommendations
can i propose an amendment to the
recommendation to counsel
item five and replace the word
prepare with draft it's a very minor
change
could i have a seconder for that
proposal please
thank you councillor cargill so
the recommendations are on pages
11 and 12. there are 12 of them in total
i do not propose to read them out
because
you're all capable of reading the first
three recommendations
are for cabinet and recommendations
4 to 12 are recommendations to counsel
can i have a second for all those
recommendations please counselor
pemberton
uh members of cabinet uh
are you in favor of the recommendations
the green agreed thank you
uh given what was actually uh all the
contributions from cabinet
i would assume that is unanimous
yes yes yes
right moving on to item five
which is the joint cabinet stroke
executive committee of stratford on
irvine and warwick district councils
these are the proposals for the
government's arrangements for a joint
cabinet executive committee
between stratford and warwick district
councils
for progressing a joint local
development plan
you will see it is an extremely detailed
paper
there have been iterations between
ourselves and warwick on this
i would make one point that the review
of these arrangements will be conducted
in july
2021 i have to say
that actually they
the creation of a joint
plan for warwick and stratfor districts
i see as
a really significant step forward and i
think he's going to be
really important in creating the future
for south warwickshire councillor
pemberton used to speak
i do indeed a leader and in fact i'm
going to go further than
than you i would say that the work of
a joint a local plan is the
most critical piece of work that these
two authorities will undertake
um it absolutely comes to the heart of
the shaping of the communities
across south warwickshire it will speak
to and give life to our key priorities
and strategies
across this authority uh not least of
which
uh relate to to climate change um
i am pleased to report that the work
that has already been done
between the two authorities has amply
demonstrated
that there is a willingness and a desire
to work together to create a
holy new plan that meets the needs
of our communities moving forward pretty
much to the middle of the century
and may i please thank uh councillor
harvey for stepping up
to the plate to be one of the two joint
uh chairs of the uh the member group
uh to be shared by uh uh his opposite
number
uh across at uh warwick uh
and um i'm looking forward um to
hearing the results of the stakeholder
events
that have been uh been taking place and
this is an exciting piece of work and
commend uh the the progress of this
joint plan
um from here on in to its uh conclusion
by the early part of 2023 i do quit i do
keep trying to move that to sort of
january 22 but
uh john carefort keeps pushing back
every time i i bring the
i bring the dates forward but i do live
in hope chairman
it's not a small undertaking councillor
pemberton
uh councillor harvey and then councillor
cargill
uh thank you mr chairman um i'm about to
deal with a matter of detail i apologize
for that
but i i don't know of any other i think
this is the appropriate time to do it
um mr grafton will know that i have uh
been in touch with him about this
particular point
and he may have a view can i refer you
to page 102
paragraph 2.7 in the appendix
for the sake of clarification uh
i have suggested to mr grafton and i
suggest to members of cabinet
that the word that the sentence be
prolonged to include the words
as observers
so that the role of those members in
participating
is absolutely clear observers are there
to watch
they are not members in the full sense
with speaking and voting rights as a
normal member would be
so i suggest i don't know whether i i
need to propose that or whether that can
simply be noted
or what the precise process might be but
i do think it's an important minor
qualification
okay can i ask mr grafton to comment
please
yes certainly chairman so if you look at
the preceding
um paragraph which is 2.6
you can see there that the proposal is
that um
members from each political group um
at stratford and at warwick who are not
represented on the
joint cabinet or the executive
can attend meetings as observers this is
very much along the lines of your own
cabinet meetings in fact and
um councillor junard chairman of the
council councillor dixon
and also chair of the osc are invited
that word observers gives a special
status as you know because they're
actually invited specifically to the
meeting and subject to your consent
chairman
can can speak the role of
other councillors that's in 2.7 is
slightly different
in the sense that they're not actually
specifically invited to the meeting so
they don't automatically
come into the meeting as more than just
an ordinary counsellor
they can attend i'd be hesitant about
calling them observers
only for that reason because it would
confuse
the difference in status between what i
would call proper observers
as set out in 2.6 and
on people who don't have those
privileges as in 2.7
well thank you mr grafton uh
can a summary of what you said be
captured in the minutes please
okay councillor cargill then council of
pemberton
thank you i'm a little bit confused on
that last point i'm just wondering
whether or not it needs to be more
explicit then
in that 2.2.6 uh sorry 2.7
um because otherwise it's it's a
somewhat
uh obscure little point that uh cancer
mr grafton has raised um perhaps subtle
too subtle um
i think perhaps we can just elaborate on
that one and i understand exactly what
council have is saying
uh i'm just concerned a little bit about
that um can i just pick up a little
point
that counter pemberton made about the
local plan as well and of course we had
some
of the county members had a meeting
about the local transport plan which of
course cuts across
all of our uh districts as well so again
it's an important one to ensure that we
we work closely with uh county highways
colleagues on that particular point
and finally i'd just like to say that
there's a huge amount of work
on these these two documents let alone
the ones that are coming
forward now and
congratulations to the officers because
it's a huge amount of work
uh but i am just a bit concerned that
making sure that we are fully resourced
to to do this and make make it happen in
an expeditious manner because that's why
i only concern about this we've got to
make sure that we can get it done within
the
ambitious time scales that uh mr grafton
has actually
submitted to us thank you thank you
and fortunately we have councillor
pemberton scheduled to speak next
and i'm sure he will pick up the points
point you raised mark
sorry councillor cargill councillor
pemberton
thank you leader um i think actually um
i i
i was i would disagree slightly with
councillor cargill i think actually
um the the wording is right in 2.6
observers may be invited by uh the chair
of a committee
to speak those who attend a meeting have
no rights of audience
and so i think actually the wording is
correct in that it's
that it opens the opportunity for a
wider
membership of the of both councils to
attend
meetings and i think that any
opportunity for members to
be abreast of the process as it runs
through
is a good thing um there will
be times when uh the the this group has
to
uh discuss uh fairly technical and
at times uh matters where there needs to
be some thought
about where where the potential landing
might be for certain
approaches and so i think there is a
mechanism within the group around
um how that is all reported out and i
think anybody attending
those meetings will will need to be
cognizant of that
because there will be undoubtedly areas
of discussion
um uh where the the group
needs to be able to think its thought
processes through
uh and then come to and come to a
landing so
i think that we that that will be part
and parcel of the process
finally i think that um
to reassure councillor cargill um myself
and my opposite number
councillor john cook at warwick uh are
all over
the uh the resource piece for this
uh there's an awful lot of work uh and
discussion around how
how the how the officers will deliver
upon this
uh and the project plan itself and there
will be dedicated project
resource project management resource to
this
um both councillor john cook and i are
absolutely
clear that our policy officers
need the additional resource of
professional project management
to deliver on this project on time
and that that is part and parcel of uh
what is going to be delivered and that
that is agreed by both authorities the
the mechanics of how that will actually
be delivered is
is still for some further discussion so
uh that's uh pretty much all i've got at
this point thank you
thank you councillor barker and then
councillor harvey and then councillor
junior
i simply wanted to suggest that i
imagine
although i haven't got it in front of me
that the constitution
or implied in the constitution is a
definition of observer
as i suspect darren was trying to define
there
and therefore it's patently obvious that
we don't need
the service in but i understand why
harvey might have thought it was
necessary councillor harvey
um i think it's been a very useful
helpful discussion and i think mr
grafton
has done the business by um
shooting down my proposition on the back
on the grounds of
sound logic um the the long and the
short of it is
if the terms of reference badge you as
an observer
you're an observer if it doesn't bad you
as an observer
you're not an observer and if that's
that understanding is reflected
in the minutes and is communicated
effectively down the line
when these terms of reference are acted
upon i'm a happy bunny
thank you councillor harvey it's good to
hear you're a happy bunny
uh counselor junaid
yes as a as an observer to the cabinet
uh
i hope you will feel that i do construct
uh contribute constructively
and i hope that that will be the same
going forward
under 2.6 in this cabinet as well
just a question that at our current
cabinet
i believe other councillors can
currently
contribute questions on specific items
but presumably this will not be allowed
under this
uh under 2.7 could you clarify that
please
can i just add that in a cabinet
councillors can speak at the discretion
of the chair
and i've normally exercised that
discretion and i think it would be up to
the chairs
of these committees to decide on a way
on how they wish to approach it
okay so in that case moving to pages 93
and 94 the recommendations to counsel
are 0.1 and the recommendations to the
cabinet
0.2 you've all read them
uh cabinet members are you happy with
the recommendations to council
and the recommendations to cabinet great
great great great great thank you
members of cabinet we now move on to
uh agenda item six revenue and capital
budget
uh 2021 22 and this
is councillor harvey uh
thank you mr chairman um
the budget process this year has been um
more involving more involving of
different parts of the uh
of the council than has previously been
the case we've also
been out for consultation in our usual
way to
businesses and local residents via the
survey
um the essence of this
of these budget proposals are that we
find ourselves in hard times
due largely to pandemic
our reserves our general reserves during
the year
will have more than halved our priority
for the future as far as possible is to
preserve
the provision of services that we
already provide
our uncertainty our great uncertainty
is the spending review which has been
postponed
for the last three years and is now
promised for
2021 on the basis
that that happens we have put together a
budget
and a medium medium-term financial
strategy over the next five years
which the section 151 officer has
approved
which enables us to maintain our head
above water so to speak
in reserve terms by preserving 2.6
million pounds in the fifth year
in terms of reserves we are doing this
uh primarily by drawing on three sources
overwhelmingly we are transferring
earmarked reserves
to general fund reserves we have
undertaken
uh significant cost savings uh through
things like joint appointments with with
warwick and thirdly
we are charging uh our
residents uh increased amount of money
through council tax i.e
a band five council tax rate will go up
by five pounds
in this budget there are other charges
which are well known which are
included and i'm pleased to say that the
early signs
to do with the garden waste scheme are
extremely positive
and encouraging and on that basis i
think this is a
sound well thought through responsible
budget which above all preserves
uh services for the future
for this year and leaves us in the
position where we can
consider succeeding future once we know
what the spending review review turns
out to hold for us
thank you mr chairman thank you uh
councillor cargill
thank you leader i've just got to say
that not being a terribly good
money person i'm an engineer okay i'm an
engineer but
i'm not a money person but i've gone
through this as we have done now for
some months
um kicking it backwards and forwards
trying to work out the best
solution to to plug the hole in that
finances
i think that castle harvey and george
and the team have done an excellent job
on this and again i go back to what we
said at the beginning of this
we're trying to do the best for our
residents and it be it's beholden on us
to do that
we must do our very very best i can only
say well done
and uh and congratulations on what i
think is in the circumstances
an excellent budget thank you councillor
cargill
uh i see no other members of cabinet
wishing to speak so
counselor junior uh you have a question
and you want to put the case
from ons yes the question is a
clarification if i might
i was told that uh parking charges for
car parks out of the district had been
uh
deferred but on page 164
2.2 third bullet point
it clearly says that if that that the
district council is investigating the
principle
of introducing charging in district car
parks outside stratford town
could you clarify on that one whether
that is a mistake or whether that is the
intention
and then secondly the overview and
scrutiny committee
uh there was a call-in to the overview
and scrutiny committee
uh and there we found that that because
of the changes that had been made
uh to the constitution in the cove as a
result of kovin 19
uh we couldn't have the the complete
debate
uh i i'd would like to make sure that uh
that
i believe that the the officers are
reviewing that particular part of the
constitution
but i'd just like to be able to have a
surety that that will go forward
mr hill do you wish to respond to
councillor junior
yes on on the um heading that's in in
the uh medium term financial plan which
uh as
councillor junior suggests
does uh the um
the charging and district car parts
that's entirely my
fault it it i shouldn't have picked out
that heading it was the top heading on
the list of
potential uh extra areas uh
that we may or may not be able to
generate income or change
charges i shouldn't have picked that one
and it should just be
car parking generally that is the
heading there
thank you uh mr hill and given all the
work you've put into the budget
and how long it's taken and how complex
it is
i'm surprised only one small error
slipped through
mr grafton you wish to respond on
calling
yes thank you chairman and i can confirm
that there will be a report coming
to council on the 22nd of february
which amongst other things will contain
proposals
on process for calling the idea being to
revert back to the pre-covid
um procedure for calling um instead
thank you mr grafton uh so i
uh councillor barker you wish to speak
forgive me i just wanted to add a small
amount to that having read
the um items that are coming out of the
lga and out of the cca actually
i'm talking about how many things are
going to
be ending in terms of the covid
regulations come
may um and there are plenty we need to
be aware of this one included
thank you councillor barker so i see no
one else wishing to speak
so if i move to the recommendations to
the cabinet
on page 111 there are two there
and uh recommendations to council
there are three can i have your
agreement to the recommendations members
of cabinets
agreed
thank you so we move on to
agenda item seven and this is once again
councillor harvey treasury management
strategy statement
and annual investment strategy chairman
and annual investment strategy
thank you councillor harvey i stand
corrected
thank you mr chairman there's an annual
requirement under the guidance
issued by the ministry for housing
communities and local government
for councils to draw up and approve an
annual investment strategy that meets
the chartered institute
of public finance and accountancy's
treasury management code of practice
this council's proposed treasury
management statement is set out
on pages 175 to 204
for the forthcoming year in appendix one
i draw attention
uh of members of the cabinet to just one
aspect of this appendix
on page 183 you'll see that the
expectation for
investment returns in the immediate
future remains not low
but exceptionally low and given the
uncertainty
of the times we live in the prospect of
any rise in investment returns
in is both uncertain and modest
appendix 2 on pages 205 216
sets out the proposed capital and
investment strategy for the period
2021 22 to 20 25
26. this proposal provides the framework
within which it's intended
that the council should make its capital
and investment decisions
over the next five years on the
assumption
the certain assumption that members of
the cabinet
have familiarized themselves with this
paper and subject to any questions
they may have i ask that approval is
given to recommendations one to four
as set out in the summary at the head of
this paper
thank you mr chairman thank you
councillor harvey i
see no one um wishing to speak on the
issue
so can i have your agreement to
recommendations one to four on page 171
please
members of cabinet great
thank you so we now move on to agenda
item 8
prudential indicators and once again
it's councillor harvey
once again thank you mr chairman
in conjunction with considering its
budget for the fourth coming year the
council is required by the sip for
prudential code to set prudential
indicators that ensure that its capital
investment plans
are affordable prudent and sustainable
the paper under consideration sets out
the fact is that the council
through its section 151 officer is
required to take into account
when considering the affordability in
its particular circumstances
of its intended capital expenditure over
the period of the medium-term financial
strategy
and the affordability of the capital
financing requirement to which this
intended expenditure may give rise
members of the cabinet will have noted
that the intention
set out in para 3.6.1
on page 221 to incur expenditure of 5
million pounds in the materials
recycling facility
as indicated in the first table on page
221
and the financing requirements to which
this will give rise
as set out in the subsequent table in
para
3.6.2 the section
151 officer has satisfied himself that
the terms associated with the course
this course of action will in his view
meet the requirements
set out in para 2.7
the section 151 officer has also noted
the recommendation to council to be
considered
under the subsequent item item nine
uh the recommendation number one of that
paper
that the amount of the loan in
connection with the material recycling
facility of five
million pounds should be increased to
eight million pounds
for the purposes of this paper the
section 1501 officer
has not assumed that the recommendation
will be made
nor that it will be subsequently agreed
by
council he is able to state however
that should this recommendation be made
to and approved
by council he would continue to be
satisfied
that the requirements of para 2.7 of
this paper
would be met the cabinet is therefore
asked to approve
the recommendations set out in the
summary at the head of this paper
that the proposed prudential indicators
for the forthcoming year
be approved thank you mr chairman thank
you
councillor harvey and it's very nice to
see that uh
items eight and items nine have been
linked
uh so without further ado members of
cabinet
are you happy with the recommendation on
page
two one seven agreed
thank you members of cabinet so agenda
item
nine investment in material recycling
facility
uh councillor shenton
thank you leader and the paper covering
pages this paper covers pages two two
three two two five four concerns funding
for the mrf project
in recommendations one and three and the
administrative
matter as highlighted in recommendation
intrinsically in recommendation one what
i'm seeking today is approval to
recommend to council the repre the
replacement of the
previous approval for up to 5.1 million
and this to be amended to 8 million
the reasons for this are quite simply
that by investing 8 million we'll have a
bigger more flexible
turnkey facility that uses less manual
labor and more artificial intelligence
robots and scanners
these can be reprogrammed in minutes
this should allow us to end up with a
cleaner
and more consistent recycler product to
sell in the market
the market's seen some changes during
the pandemic but even
before this many countries were putting
up barriers and only accepting
ultra clean recycling something that
this facility
will achieve in addition as highlighted
in subsection 1.8
and the paragraphs below it entitled
plastics
you'll see that low-grade plastics can
be accommodated more effectively
one of the big problems has been cling
film
type products which some earths or most
nerves cannot
successfully deal with but this new
facility can deal with that
the full background to this is found in
section 1
whilst section 2 outlines the options
and section 3 deals with the financial
aspects
even with this increase in the capital
investment the net gate fee
is expected to be around the target that
was in the original proposal
and approval with the expected life on
this machinery being
30 plus years the projected gate fee
could be less if spare capacity at the
facility is sold to other parties
because there is clearly a market for
this facility
the murder remains a very attractive way
to mitigate the increases in gate fees
by controlling the process with our
partners
the facility will be the most advanced
of its kind in the uk
and one of the most advanced in the
world
provided as a turnkey facility by a
company
with proven ability and solutions in
this area of recycled waste management
deposit return schemes and end user
responsibilities will add additional
challenges if and when the government
does eventually mandate this
but this is true for all murphs not
just this one we will receive
uh six percent interest from uh
sherbourne recycling limited which is
the
the company that will run this with uh
current
public works loan board rates of less
than two percent
meaning that we will gain int on the
interest on the turn
effectively we receive six percent and
whatever the rate is at the public works
loan board which currently is
around round or below two percent
we make four percent the capital would
be paid back over a long
return of 25 years recommendation two
gives the portfolio holder delegated
authority to deal with matters
before the shareholder panel after
consulting with the deputy chief
executive and the head of community and
operational
services whilst recommendation 3 is
concerned with setting up the loan
agreement and the service level
agreement with sherbourne recycling
as you know i'm a keen supporter of this
project that is the best way to control
the gate fees
which are forecast to continue rising
it's the best way to control the quality
of the end recyclers
and the best way to control the ultimate
destination
and the best way to ensure that as much
product is taken
out of the waste stream and recycled
i therefore ask you to approve the three
recommendations to counsel
as contained on pages two two three and
two to four
of your pack thank you leader
uh thank you councillor shenton and i
have councillor cargill and then
councillor harvey wishing to speak
councillor cargill
thank you uh council shenzhen just a
question um i'm assuming that we haven't
signed the contract with the end
supplier on this as
yet uh the the with machine x we have um
uh machine x the the company gmi machine
next i think it's called
um they will supply the machinery we
haven't signed the contract the full
contract on the civil
part of it um all this is coming
together because we need approval from
all the
uh all the authorities first to move
ahead
uh effectively this becomes the last
point um
before we start to start sign the
contracts themselves but we have
all the quotes in apart from the final
one on the civil
side of it which will come in later this
month
but it's expected to come in under what
we've
budgeted for thank you now the reason i
ask is that obviously
it's far better to have these sort of
changes occur before we sign a contract
um i just say that these sort of things
are inevitable in these sort of
processes
where new technologies come along you
know i'm a supporter of this
the scheme anyway and i'm just quite
glad that we've now arrived at this
particular
technological solution uh being a
technological
person and i hope that they've got the
tech right
i'm sure they have there are plants in
europe operating
similar not perhaps as advanced as this
already
so i think this is exactly the right
route to go and yes
it's going to give a longer rate of
return um
over the 30-year life of the plant so
yes i'm supportive of it
thank you councillor cargill and thank
you for reminding us earlier on in the
proceedings that you are an engineer
counselor harvey and then councillor
kettle
thank you mr chairman the the couple of
points i'd make
um number one uh while nobody wants to
see
more money uh being put into a project
then is absolutely necessary this is a
this appears to be one of those
instances where you get what you pay for
and we're paying more and we're getting
more um
i i i'm persuaded by the arguments uh
about
uh the the improved technology and the
high quality of recycling that will
result
but the other thing i would point to is
table three gives you the clue
setting out the partners this um this
process of scrutiny
uh well first of all we're sharing the
risk with other partners
but we are not in in this are on our own
um it's good to share
risk and secondly um the scrutiny that
we are applying
to this request will be being replicated
by those
other partner organizations and they
have to be persuaded
as well and provided they are i suspect
they will be going through the same sort
of process that we are
and um we can take some comfort from the
fact that this isn't just
stratford making this decision uh to
support the murph on this basis
this is a consortium of uh authorities
that are acting
hopefully in the same way so i'm i am
reassured of course speaking with my
portfolio hat on as mr hill will no
doubt
point out um if he had the chance uh we
are we are lending
up to eight million pounds and we've
virtually got a guaranteed return
we can't lose money on it in that sense
so i'm all in favor go to it mr shenton
thank you councillor harvey um
councillor kettle and then councillor
jennings
councillor kettle thank you mr chairman
um
i mean i note in table three to which uh
caster harvey referred the
uh investment required from stratford is
actually less than the eight million at
seven 7.3 which is
um demonstrates that there is some
hopefully headroom within that eight
million um
council chancellor i hope that is the
case and there is no further seven
thousand that's going to be introduced
at some stage
um but two questions um
are we confident at this stage because
we have seen
notably on the boundaries of my ward a
very large public sector
contract which increases um
exponentially every time somebody
decides to press the button on the
calculator
uh are we convinced that this figure
is one that is deliverable um
and who is carrying out the due
diligence
on that and secondly will
we have continuous feedback
um in terms of some sort of financial
reporting to demonstrate
that this project is kept under tight
financial control
um not as other public sector contracts
of which
we've heard a lot about in the council
chamber in the past
counselor kettle can i just observe that
with you on cabinet
i suspect there will be absolutely no
chance of evading scrutiny
councillor shenton do you wish to
respond to councillor cattle
i think maybe you've said what i was
about to say
um but uh the the reason that we have um
a shareholder panel is for the portfolio
holder to be
involved um whoever that portfolio
holder is
at the present that's me um to be
involved and it will be reported back
on a regular basis the the uh all
all the the councils themselves are
scrutinizing
the contracts are locked in they're not
you know
not going to drift out it's only the
civil part of it that we're
we're still working on because we're
trying to
to build in if you like some value
engineering some
take out cost in there once that's this
once that's agreed the costs are there
they're fixed we won't be coming back
for more
on the score of the table
table 3 shows 7.3 million and we're
asking for 8 million
it's purely to give us that contingency
because the contingency would save us
coming back again
for anything else there's always
something that's likely to bite us
at some point i guess but the reason for
asking for the eight million
uh is purely so that we have a
contingency
thank you uh councillor shenton
uh councillor jennings okay once again
just a few words i think i think it's an
excellent
long-term investment which again will
benefit the people of this district
thank you councillor jennings a a very
appropriate note on which to end the
contributions
uh from cabinet uh i have to say that
the discussions we've had in the
background
on this project actually do demonstrate
how carefully we do approach things i
think it's an excellent project
i think the reality actually is that
it's about the only opportunity we have
to future proof
uh material recycling so with that
members of cabinet the recommendations
to council
are on pages two two three and two to
four recommendations one two three
can i have your approval to those
recommendations please members of
cabinet
great agreed thank you so
moving swiftly on uh agenda item 10
preventing homelessness in warwickshire
a multi-agency approach
councillor barker thank you mr chairman
um this report begins on page 255
with the recommendations um the first of
which
is that we are going to note the
contents of the strategy
the strategy just to give you a little
bit of background because it does seem
to have been
worked on for a very very long time um
was that uh the housing board sought
approval from the health and well-being
board on which
i serve on our behalf
um to look at the uh the homelessness
strategy for the whole county that will
then be running through
with all the districts and boroughs
having
completed their view on the strategy to
the health and wellbeing board itself
on uh in march this year i could tell
you the date but i'd have to open my
diary
um the reasoning behind this strategy
is that the homelessness reduction act
of 2017
gave us the there's a particular
reference in it to the prevention
the prevention duty and the duty to
refer
the whole aim being one that we
hold dear which is the permanent
prevention of homelessness
um you can see the full strategy in
appendix one um the
major
emphasis on this is to improve health of
rough sleepers or homeless people to
look at financial inclusion to enhance
and improve
uh young people's services
to prevent domestic abuse and also to
have better focused housing related
support
for those who might be leaving prison
um i would just highlight when you look
at prior it's priority
three domestic abuse that that
seems to be the the one that most people
were agreeing on given particularly
given
that this the work on the a lot of the
work on this was done
during the pandemic when we saw quite
a rise in domestic violence
um one thing that has come out
positively from kovid which i would just
like to highlight is
we're talking about digital inclusion
being important and i think that's
become ever more so as people have not
been able to leave home and meet people
so digital inclusion is now something
that's perhaps even further on our radar
than it was
before and i would highlight that
um after discussions with heads of
housing
it was determined that housing
allocations and policy
in terms of veterans needed to be looked
at so i will just refer that to
any of the policy work we're doing that
on that
coming up um if you turn
to page 261 through to
page 307 you have the multi-agency
approach and i again would just
highlight that it's
the number of people working together
again
um this is something that we've
certainly seen be easier
during the kovid pandemic and that we've
got out of our silos and worked together
but the homelessness approach is
certainly multi-agency
uh and i see i was one of the authors of
this report which
came as some surprise to me but never
mind um so but in the
i'm being sarcastic because i've worked
on it for ages but i just didn't write
it
um that
the what les cable the portfolio holder
for adult social carer who sort of
leads this um he makes the point
that a place to live is a basic human
need and the lack of a
home blights the lives of too many in
our community
and i would completely endorse that we
then just move through to the strategy
itself
i've already highlighted the
homelessness reduction act which is the
emphasis behind it
um and i i would uh i would commend
this strategy and report to you
and ask that uh turn my pages back
we um recommend the three
recommendations to council thank you
thank you
uh i've got councillor kettle and
councillor parry wishing to speak and
then
councillor junior councillor kettle then
councillor parry then councillor junaid
uh councillor barker thank you for this
um
i mean really important document uh i
think you know the cove
era and of course the bitingly cold
weather at the moment
demonstrates how incredibly important
uh preventing homelessness is um you
very briefly mentioned
veterans um can you reassure me
um because i think i am the forces uh
representative on this cabinet that um
that the military covenant is will be
reinforced by this document
uh and ensure that our veterans who find
themselves in difficulty which after all
does represent a disproportionate high
number of veterans for
many reasons that um
we do understand and reasons a lot of
people don't understand can we ensure
that
that they will be given uh continuing
and um um
robust support from this so i've just
seen cancer pemberton's comments
do you wish to respond absolutely yes
and
i will make it a priority just to uh
to highlight that with our department
itself um and then pass it
on to warwick to make sure that they are
thinking the same
particularly because they have um a
housing stock
and therefore they can do more with it i
might have a word with orbit as well
there we go
thank you councillor parry thank you
leader i just wanted to highlight
and reinforce thanks to councillor
barker
for this outstanding outstanding piece
of work
which just demonstrates how it has been
really business as usual during the
pandemic
that this such a such a major piece of
work
has been undertaken but also i think it
again reinforces how well
districts can work together for the good
of
everyone and i think it is another
shining example
of where stratford has been working
together with warwick
plus obviously the other district in
boris but it just reinforces
the importance um and and really
engenders
the sort of cooperation that we are
working with other people
so thank you councillor barker thank you
piece of work
and the officers as well yeah it is very
beneficial
valuable points extremely well made
councillor junaid yes i had a specific
message from
councillor jenny fred fragili uh in
support
of this approach and but she
specifically wanted to say a big thank
you to the officers for the work that
has been done on this
and she welcomes the support structures
that will enable people to move on with
their lives
uh so she she's had a specific request
to me that i put that forward to the
cabinet
thank you thank you councillor junaid
i appreciate that yes i really do
because
the the officers and there aren't that
many of them
have worked incredibly hard on this
stuff and it is com
really complicated and difficult and
what we've achieved
in terms of business and you as usual
has been great so thank you it's nobody
else
it's very nice to get cross-party
support counselor junior when a job has
been
extremely well done so without further
ado then recommendations to council
one two and three on page 255
members of cabinet are you supportive of
those recommendations
agreed great great thank you
so moving on then agenda item 11
health and well-being strategy councilor
barker
another strategy that has been in
gestation for what seems like a very
very very long time you may remember
back
um that we did have a year of well-being
which was
right royally ended by um kovid
we were just beginning to talk about
what we were going to do after the year
of well-being
when a meeting which we were holding in
coventry
was in in late february
last year um was interrupted by lots and
lots and lots of the medics sitting
there
their phones were going off and one by
one
the more senior got more and more junior
we're leaving because obviously
it was the beginning of the pandemic um
and
our numbers were massively reduced and
that's the last meeting we had together
so a lot of this work actually has been
done
remotely which has been extraordinary as
well
anyway this is the 20 to 25 strategy
uh four recommendations um
with your indulgence i will i would just
refer you to the case studies
on page 355 onwards
and to the extremely useful um
i think one calls it a pictogram showing
the wider determinants of health
etc on page 354 facing
and i always think that because what
we're doing in terms of
place and um
and well-being that it's good to
understand how all the links work
because i've got to say it took me a
while to shake out
what these links were anyway i'll just
refer you to the case studies
which reflect the priorities so there's
a case study here of actually
training um locally trained youth
support workers
in supporting our first priority which
is helping children and young people to
get their best start in life
then priority two creative health
interventions
some of you may have seen art projects
happening particularly online for people
who
have been vulnerable or lonely during
covid um
and that's that's part of the helping
residents improve their mental health
and well-being
um and then
which is which was the second priority
and then priority three
um reducing inequalities and health
outcomes and the wider determinants of
health
and those are the buzz phrases you will
always hear
in this public health realm um
the wider determinants of health being
those other things not
just medicine and whether we're fit and
well and you know
we've got a broken leg or whatever but
actually
where we live how we live who we live
with
whether we have bad habits good habits
um it's a lot more nebulous
but can be pinned down through the work
that we've been doing
uh particularly through the joint
strategic needs assessment
and the action plan that went with that
um i believe we'll be getting that in
july
coming up um so these things all
contribute together what i'd like to
just do
is is look at the recommendation number
four
um and if you turn to uh
section 5.2
um that we contribute to both the
healthy citizens forum
south warwickshire health and well-being
delivery group stratfor social inclusion
partnership
and the various um well-being boards
you know with the place-based approach
meeting local needs and we share best
practice and work together and i think
that's one of the most important things
about this
uh and then in six uh sorry that's 5.2
where's my 6.2 gone
nope i've got that wrong sorry i've lost
one of my numbers nevermind
the it's the proposal that we um
consider adding a further category
for inclusion in all reports which
detailing the implications of the
reports content on the health and
well-being of district residents
and as i've just given you a counter
through the
wider determinants of health i would
be extremely pleased if we
uh major on putting making sure that
well-being
is something that we do use as another
one of the prisms we look through
when we're looking at all our policy
other than that if there are any
questions
please ask and i commend the
recommendations council
thank you councillor barker councillor
junior do you wish to speak
um just that i would like to be able to
offer the support
from ulster our chair ulster youth
project in ulster
and if there's anything we can do on the
locally trained youth support workers
along with the
project that ulster town council is
running then i i would like to be
involved
please keep me updated on that thank you
councillor junior
councillor kettle
i'll just go repeat what i said on the
previous issue
um the importance of um buying into the
military covenant which this
local authority has done in the past uh
and it is
critical that we do support our
ex-servicemen given that the awful lot
of their
um not clearly all except some have
those
have mental health problems but an awful
lot of those who do have been caused by
serving this country in one form or
another and that we must ensure
this and any other district were
involved with um
is able to recognize their contribution
that they have made at considerable
personal costs themselves
and that we must make sure we protect
them as well as any other local
authority
in the country thank you councillor
kettle
uh a point well made so without further
ado
cabinet the recommendations to council
are on page 335
the recommendations are one to four
i'm sure we have read them can i have
your support for those recommendations
to
council please agreed
thank you so moving on
uh the next item is wellsborne airfield
update and
this is in my name and it is just
literally
uh an update on the progress and i have
to say the progress has not been
as fast as we would have liked but it
has been
severely disrupted by covid
um there has been a memorandum of
understanding in place between the
council and the owners of the airfield
which makes sure that aviation can
continue on the site
it's not been without its controversy
and that leads me on to uh
raise the issue um
that we do get emails from
residents about this and i just want to
read you this that mr grafton
has prepared for me yesterday the
council
received an email from a member of the
public who takes issue with the two
sentences
in paragraph 1 4 of the report
the mlu has not been without controversy
and there have been a number of
allegations that the terms of the mou
have been breached the person concerned
claims that some or all of the
allegations of either one
not been fully investigated or resolved
or two
that they've been dismissed or three
that they've been buried by the council
in contrast the council believes that
his allegations
and those submitted by a second member
of the public have been thoroughly
investigated on the council's
corporate complaints policy none of the
complaints were upheld through that
process
but as usual in that situation both
individuals
were advised of their right to appeal
the decision
to the local government and social care
ombudsman
in the case of the person who wrote to
the council yesterday
he did submit an appeal to the ombudsman
and that appeal was dismissed
in the case of the other individual he
has not as yet
exercised his right of appeal the second
member of the public
also submitted a complaint against the
district councillor
under the members code of conduct after
hearing from the councillor
and taking into account the views of the
two independent persons
the monitoring officer decided there had
been no breach of the code
and that case is now closed the second
sentence reads
determining this i.e the allegations has
been further complicated by restrictions
that have arisen
as a result of the curving 19 pandemic
the member of the public concern says
that some information that he believes
helps to
to support his own allegations have only
been revealed through
freedom of information requests the
council believes it's acted responsibly
throughout
when weighing up the level of public
interest in these
information requests as opposed to other
public law factors
such as commercial confidentiality there
is absolutely no doubt that the
world born airfield issue has not been
without its controversy
however where we are at the moment
is uh negotiations are ongoing with the
owners of the airfield and their agents
uh these central ground repositioning of
the runway
and aviation facilities to give us a
more sustainable airfield
the other point i would actually make is
that the department for transport
has shown a very keen interest in the
future wells born airfield
they see it as an important part of the
network of general aviation
airfields uh so
work is ongoing at the moment things are
moving forward
nowhere near as fast as we would like
but they have been
slowed down by covid we are working
thoroughly diligently and as quickly as
we can
to get a solution uh to the wells born
airfield issue
councillor parry used to speak
thank you chairman firstly i'd actually
just like to thank
yourself and the portfolio holder
together with the officers
for all their hard work in protecting
the flying functions of wellspawn
airfield
which i know is greatly appreciated
by my residents as you can see from my
background
wellsborne airfield is a little bit is
very very close to my heart so
the fact that we've been able to keep
the flying functions going is fantastic
but what i would really find helpful is
a little bit in view of what you've just
highlighted i would really welcome some
clarity
on what you and the officers believe
could be the implications of actually
withdrawing the mou
in respect to the operation of the
airfield because i know this is
you know um residents are very concerned
because obviously there's so many
livelihoods
linked to the airfield um and
and and the job side of things so i just
wonder whether there's some clarity
on removing or withdrawing the mou
at this moment in time i will answer as
best i can i may then
look to mr grafton for
moral support um
there is no doubt about it the mou has
kept
the aviation facilities in place
uh it's enabled us to actually continue
uh negotiations
um that along with the uh cp
compulsory purchase order in the
background
that's what is moving us steadily
forward in terms of
negotiating a unacceptable solution
uh i don't know whether you would like
to comment mr grafton or
mr perks um i might leave
much of what's to be said to mr perks
except to say that
a compulsory purchase order is simply
the very last resort
for any local authority and that is
why partly the mou is in place
um in the sense that if we can't
use that as an umbrella to advance
our discussions uh then then it was
evidence that can be used at some point
to help with the cpo but we shouldn't
underestimate
the um importance and
mightiness of such a decision to to
start
a cpo process thank you
thank you mr perks do you wish to add
anything um
yes i'd like to reiterate what's been
sort of said already but
um it's probably worth reminding the
cabinet that when we started this
process the airfield was destined for
closure there would be no to served on
all tenants and there was to be no sort
of aviation continuing
um the mou has at least whilst it may
not have
satisfied everything we'd hoped for it
has at least kept aviation sort of
continuing at the site as councillor
parry pointed out
um the other thing i would say is that
cpo is a process not an event
and under the compulsory purchase order
process we want to have our best chance
of winning
part of that means that we're required
to see if we can secure a future for the
airfield through negotiation with the
current owners
um we are doing that at the moment and
looking for a solution the cpo
is not off the table but it it needs to
be conducted in
conjunction with negotiated the rightful
owners of the land
the mou is at the moment keeping
aviation going whilst we have those
discussions where as i pointed out at
the start but when we started this
process
um the flying was deceased from the site
so whilst it may not be perfect
on balance and also on the balance of
the public interest test i feel that the
memorandum of understanding has got
value and is
sort of doing what it was intended to do
thank you mr perks
uh i say no further comments from uh
cabinet so the recommendation on page
361
the report is noted the budget to fund
the compulsory purchase order is
maintained
can i have your agreement to that
recommendation members of cabinet
very positively agreed thank you
absolutely
so moving on
deputy leader please portfolio uh
allocation of community infrastructure
levy funds
uh thank you chair and uh members um
the recommendation uh before you is in
relation
to the allocation of community
infrastructure levy funds
um members will be aware from the papers
that
um in essence there are more projects
that have
come forward that could
be considered as they meet a number of
corporate priorities
of this council but we do have to come
to a balance
judgment about which projects
we think should be supported for
community infrastructure levy
and it is my recommendation um members
of cabinets
that two projects in particular um
receive an allocation of funds
taking the two projects together means
that we will actually spend
more than we currently have in in terms
of still funds
i can however assure members uh that
there is a substantial amount of still
still fund money to to drop into the
back of the sofa so to speak
in very short order uh and i
am 100 confident that
um the amount of 67 993 pounds and 20
pence
which is the current anticipated
shortfall will be available from
very near-term future seal receipts and
certainly
within the time frame envelopes for both
projects
um the two projects and i'll take the
second one first is the ulster flood
risk
management scheme and i see uh
councillor cargo will want to speak in
support of that
uh undoubtedly as will cancel at june ed
um
absolutely meets uh one of our
fundamental corporate priorities
in in mitigating the impacts of
climate change and both of the projects
that are being put before
uh cabinet have been through a review by
overview and scrutiny and i think it
would be fair
to say that both projects receive that
project received
universal support and
so i i recommend that the other project
is for one evasion place which is the
high support capacity building scheme
which we've just touched on
our health and well-being strategy and
our housing strategy
and cancer fragility and counselor
junior
complemented the work done and the
importance of both of those strategies
and this scheme is a complementary
scheme to
other work that has been done done by
this council most notably
further on in the papers the the
question of purchase of properties but
also
the fred winter scheme i think it would
be fair to say
uh the overview and scrutiny uh spent
more time considering yves in place
but that was more about the detail of
the project and wanting to ensure that
uh
rather than the principle of the project
that was more about is it the you know
have we the the right operator and those
are not really things for seal to
consider
uh we're talking about are we funding a
project that will be further detailed
uh work done and further detailed
consultation about the delivery of the
project
but i think it was right and proper for
cabinet to be aware that
some discussion around the the
implementation rather than the principle
of the project and absolutely this
project hits right front and center
it is this council's avowed intention
to in all intents and purposes
end rough sleeping in this district
uh and this uh project and the sill
funding for this project
uh is a significant building block
towards that aspiration
which i know every single member of this
authority
shares so members i commend the
recommendations for
supporting cell funds on uh for both of
these projects to cabinet
and happily take any questions you've
made a very powerful case
councillor cargill and then councillor
junard
thank you leader and thank you council
pemberton i think
i've i support both of these schemes i
think are both
equally uh important schemes i'm no
doubt that
all the other schemes that are waiting
are important too
however i think the priorities have been
absolutely right the
the asian place one is vital it's not
just important it's vital
just picking up on my my my pet scheme
of course which is the
which is the flooding in ulster which
i've been uh banging on about now for a
long long time
um this is a small but important part
and i mean important uh in the in the
scheme of negotiations that i've been
uh working on now for for over four
years now it's a complex scheme
uh including funding from the housing
development
through county partners you name it
everybody's involved in
agency town council it's hugely complex
uh unfortunately it seems to have
stalled a little bit that's only because
developers i don't think wants to pay up
the money that they owe us
but we're working hard on that i'm
sending the big boys round later on
i think that this could be an uh
such an important scheme to get
australian flood risk
uh to a one in one hundred year plus
climate change uh it will relieve
so much pressure on people in the in the
town of austin
but also it allows us to re potentially
redevelop
uh one or two areas within the town as
well which are currently in flood zone
three so thank you very much indeed
everybody for
supporting this scheme that is
absolutely vital and it does affect
thousands of people and thank you thank
you
councillor barker then councillor junior
councillor barker
i i just want to compare with councillor
cargill about how
important it is to do these jobs for our
um
smaller market towns i can tell you that
the difference
that the 300 leaky dams
in our catchment in shipston has made is
absolutely extraordinary we don't we
don't seem to go much above three meters
now however flashy the flood and that
means that pretty much no
houses now are affected um so
yeah i really want to commend that one i
also i also do want to commend the
evening place one
because it is an existing um
hostel um and as uh councillor pemberton
and i
both agree we wish to end rough sleeping
to the extent that it is absolutely
possible
um in this district and we've been given
the
almost the bonus of everyone in
um during covid to take the opportunity
to do it it's costing cost of fortune
with um
bed and breakfast and so on so it's
quite clear that we do need to do
something else so with this
um with the fred winter center coming
online as well
we are nearly there thanks thank you
councillor barker councillor junard
yes i i just want to support the
uh defenses for ulster i was actually a
member
of the advisory uh board to the
environment agency
uh between 98 and and 2002
when i was responsible for supporting
the upgrade to the defenses
on two sides of the town and this needs
to be
finished in conjunction with a natural
flood management scheme
in partnership now i also have to
declare that i'm a trustee of
warwickshire wildlife trust who will be
involved in that natural flood
management
uh scheme eventually um so i just want
to put that on on
on the record now but as a ward member
uh for for the area uh around gunning's
bridge
and uh down school road uh i thoroughly
support
um the the seal allocation for flood
defenses in ulster
thank you thank you councillor junior
councillor kettle i see you wish to
speak
um yeah one for council pemberton um
can you reassure me that uh the eve
should place
improvements which i wish i absolutely
support but will be
a facility that will ensure that
homelessness across the district
uh facilities will be improved and it
won't be local to stratfor
you might say residents by themselves
absolutely it is our avowed intention to
all intents and purposes
and rough sleeping across the district
um
councillor kettle makes a good point
about uh rough sleeping across the
district and
absolutely we we're attacking it across
the whole of the district
it is fair to say that the concentration
and ecosystem of support services
that those being helped off the streets
are concentrated in the town um those
across the entire health well-being and
housing spectrum
um um and so it is not entirely
surprising
that there that there is resource there
it is not
an exclusively stratford-only solution
it is absolutely a solution
and nick cad's team and under councillor
barca's portfolio
absolutely have a district-wide approach
to this
working alongside our partners p3
amongst others so
absolutely happy to give that
reassurance that uh
and i i i will stop encroaching on
councillor barker's portfolio there
thank you councillor pemberton uh so
without further ado members of cabinet
the recommendations on page 365
recommendations one two and three uh
are you supportive of those
recommendations members of cabinet
agreement great brilliant thank you
uh so people portfolio councillor barker
proposal to purchase
additional properties for users housing
first supported housing
so just to complete uh yet more
properties that you need to be housing
people
um in first supported housing which is
basically the moving on and next steps
accommodation program um but we've got
the money
um we've got the map we can do the match
funding and again it's
this is these are acquiring homes for
um those who are the most complex and
challenging who sleep rough
um the you can see the four
recommendations here
um i am informed
that offers offers are in on three
one i believe might be viewed today um
and
that um that they are springing into
life as a team and that
yes it's tight but that getting this
done
and over the line by the 31st of march
is undoubtedly doable um there is also
the important fact that the houses that
are being looked at
are pretty much ready to move into they
don't need that much work or that much
time
on them which makes a big difference to
some of uh
compared to some of the projects that
mhclg
is uh letting through so um
i don't really think there's anything
more to it except that let's just buy
yet more houses and uh off we go
hello rock sleepers so the
recommendations
one to four on page 387
uh can i have your support for those
recommendations please members of
cabinet
agreements thank you
so the next item on the agenda is
climate change panel
recommendations these are issues arising
from overview and scrutiny committee
and i noticed that in both uh
the issues referred in appendices one
and two uh both were endorsed by osc
so i don't think we need debate those
any further
so the on block items uh
are climate change panel received the
minutes
i have no indication that uh people wish
to discuss
those so part f urgent business
17 councillor shenton
you mute councillor shenton oh
classic scoreboy era my apologies
um this concerns the the car parking
charges proposal
and further to the meeting on the 11th
of january this year
the process for taking this forward to
the next stage
has now been agreed i don't aim to go
through the reasons and background of
why we must
consider the increases as that was
debated and accepted by cabinet
on the 11th of january the paper briefly
outlines the history and the two
recommendations
recommendation one concerns the
substantive part of the original
proposal
that is to say the general parking
tariffs and i'm asking cabinet to accept
this recommendation so that we can move
forward with the increases
in line with the established parking
policy
this effectively confirms what cabinet
agreed in the previous financial year
and what was debated
and accepted on the 11th of january of
this year
one point i will make is that there's
been talk and questions about
why don't we wait until the new local
transport policy is agreed
well car parking charges do not fall
within the remit
of that policy so moving on to
recommendation
two this concerns those elements of the
proposals that are changes to parking
policy
and are highlighted at section 1.8
as i said at the meeting on the 11th of
january
2021 it is right that residents should
express the views on these
and a report as mentioned in this paper
at section 1.9
will be brought back to cabinet in due
course
i would ask cabinet to approve
recommendation too so that the public
consultation
can commence as soon as possible in fact
uh again update on that we are ready to
go on the public consultation i believe
now
in summary and conclusion i'd ask the
cabinet to approve the two
recommendations as set out at the head
of the paper
entitled off-street car parking charges
and dated today
and thank you very much that's me done
on this i i see no members of cabinet
wanting to speak so can we
agree the recommendations one and two
please read
thank you members of cabinet can i just
say i think today has been a
remarkably heavyweight agenda for
cabinet
there have been some huge issues we've
had to discuss
i think the discussion has been good
robust and i want to say
thank you all for the effort you've
obviously put in
in reading the papers which was no small
undertaking
so thank you members of cabinet and i
now declare the meeting closed
thank you chairman thank you thank you
you